last summer andre pocarasa saved up
enough money to buy a drone
[Music]
the 15 year old practiced flying every
day at his home near kiev
i'm afraid of heights but i love flying
he says i like taking pictures from up
high
but in february pocarasa's town suddenly
found itself on russia's warpath russian
tanks were spotted heading their way
ukraine's military didn't know the exact
location so they began looking for a
drone pilot drones have been a tool of
war for years but ukraine has witnessed
a proliferation of these consumer level
drones which can be owned and operated
by almost anyone from almost anywhere
giving the ukrainian military
potentially thousands of eyes in the
skies it's like game changer for
for the world this drone shop owner says
when russia invaded ukraine's military
didn't have any short-range drones so he
put out a call on facebook for civilian
drone owners to help locate russian
forces the response was overwhelming if
we
didn't have such operators and drones
who can help ukrainian army i think
kiu already could be occupied by
russian
forces more than a thousand civilians
answered the call to help including the
youngest volunteer pocarasa
the russians were only a couple of
kilometers away but the military needed
their exact coordinates pocarasa was the
only experienced drone pilot in town
i was very scared but if i didn't help
them the russians could be here in a day
he says the grade 9 student went with
his father to a nearby field and put his
drone up over the highway before long he
spotted an armored column of russian
vehicles his father sent the images and
coordinates to the military and the
russian column was destroyed pocarasa's
town was saved is she proud
his mother says it was a sleepless night
yes
i had no way of contacting them i was so
worried she says after that she insisted
they leave to poland with russian forces
now pushed out of this region the family
returned home last week
the military rewarded pocarasa with this
more advanced drone and he says proudly
he's also gained more followers on tick
tock after posting some of his videos
i was so happy that i helped he says but
also there were people in those russian
vehicles they were occupiers but still
people i don't know how to explain how i
feel about it
the weight of the experience is a lot to
carry even for the bravest 15 year old
jeff semple global news near key
[Music]